Alexes in Texas hi Alex how are you how
can I help
so we finished with baby step 1 now
we'll be on baby step 2 and so you tell
us that we have to go ahead and get the
you know work on the slowest balance to
the highest balance well my wife and I
have been discussing about her student
loan by the time we get to the student
loan for student loan will be about two
years and so she says about two years
she'll be able to apply for it they they
basically will waive what the balance
that she owes because she works at a
high risk school so she says we should
just skip that and dissipate a minimum
and that student loan they work on the
other ones who is paying well what it
does is dude she has like a special like
like a grant that if she works a certain
amount of year so that's part of high
school tribute from the actual student
from Sallie Mae one of those loans oh
she doesn't either that doesn't exist
there are high Rasik there are high risk
forgiveness programs but they're
associated they may be managed through
Sallie Mae but they're probably
associated with your state there may be
a federal implication but I don't think
she's got good information yeah because
that's what they mentioned to her like
you know chip in two years should be
what will apply where and how the actual
loan fee for given how much up to
basically naw by that time you know it's
I think it's nine seventy nine hundred
dollars how much and so by the $7,900
that's our total student loan debt no
our student all day 215 that they will
forgive seventy nine hundred dollars two
years from now
yes and what is your household income
pasa link on my after taxes either okay
after taxes is about six thousand
okay
lecture its biggest I get Commission
yeah and how much debt do you guys have
not counting your home 300,000 300,000
yes sir that's not counting a home right
yes what do you have cars credit cards
personal loans second mortgages just if
you're not yeah we got it guys you got
it man Wow okay so women you have
$300,000 are not counting your home yeah
so that's what she says like it's a
small dent because it's not even it's
not even in the discussion um what is
what break the 300k down for me cause
I'm having trouble here how much does
credit cards credit cards it's about
close to 150 okay awesome and how much
on these carbon under cars they're
basically sixty thousand dollars on -
okay so that's fifteen what's the other
ninety student loans yeah so you got a
bunch of student loans - well the
student loans but it's actually uh the
one we're discussing with that because
she has they're from different student
loans from different student loan
companies and so that's what she was
telling me for what the Amanda yeah we
all nine thousand dollars in student
loans now I got ninety in student loans
so you've got 75 yeah no it's actually
it's uh we're discussing is that there's
ninety thousand fifteen thousand or are
there different companies that shield oh
gosh they're all her student loans
yes but all from well we're discussing
of those fifteen thousand dollars they
say they will be able to only way
seventeen hundred dollars of it so when
she says that there's such a minimum
amount he says why worry about that
section of student loans
we're in two years we'll be able to pay
that off so that portion that that
student loan we should skip it and
concentrate on the other okay well Alex
let me let me just help you here I've
read through and I've heard about people
talk about student loan forgiveness
I've listened and read about mortgage
loan forgiveness --is these programs
aren't real
okay there is so much red tape and so
many different nuances inside of it I
don't want you pinning your hope to this
thing that didn't going work out so I
want you guys to make a decision about
what you're going to do for your future
this is about payoff not forgiveness
yeah it's okay if you park it for two
years because it's gonna take you longer
in two years clean up this mess and and
give it a shot but if you don't cross
every T and dot every I you're not going
to get it and if you do get it it's a
very unusual thing now it's not the ten
year program it's a high-risk thing and
usually that's a five-year basis right
or for your basis is that what this one
is exactly because that's what you told
us it's all you know that that might
actually work but you got bigger
problems than that okay
what did you run up on credit cards if
you ask me I don't know how long have
you guys been married 21 years okay all
right and so when one of the cars gonna
be sold sold is going to be a state yeah
you heard this there but run you need to
be in two Humpty's yeah you need a
skateboard to mean you got a view you
guys you didn't see anything anywhere in
any store that you hadn't bought and so
you got it you're gonna have to go your
and let the pendulum swing all the way
the other way and have a complete change
of heart and you're over here discussing
an $8,000 forgiveness when you get
150,000 in student loans $60,000 in cars
so the cars need to be gone this week or
up for sale this week don't even go look
at Amazon and if I don't even see it
every you need to get out the cards and
have a detailed in-depth plastic surgery
at your house you are way overdue for
that and then we've got to get you on a
really tight budget and then if you want
to park that to the side do the
paperwork and hopefully you get that
8,000 forgiven that's fine but you know
what you have a $300,000 story hmm
$8,000 it's just a little side bar
discussion yeah so in that sense she's
right I hope you can get it forgiven but
it doesn't solve your problem you got
such other issues you got to
that are such a bigger deal so make sure
hang on I'm gonna have Madison pick up
we're going to make sure you get you in
financial peace for the 14-day free
trial and you guys get in there start
watching the videos and get on the same
page and you really need to sell so much
stuff the kids think their neck still
you're really going to have to clean
house here man
you have a mess and radical radical
change in your behaviors it's like
you're going down the road down the
interstate at a hundred and ten miles an
hour the wrong way we just stopped and
got you off the interstate
now go under the bridge and get back on
going the right way and set your speed
limit set your screws of the speed limit
mm-hm and you'll get back and you're
going to change directions by 200 miles
an hour here yeah I mean that's that's
what you've got to do is and so it's
going to shock your system it's going to
shock the system of your crazy family
it's going to shock the system of your
broke friends that you've been running
around with spending money you didn't
have on stuff you didn't need to impress
people you don't even really like it's
gonna shock your system and you or you
need your system shocked big time and so
it has to be a radical change otherwise
you're gonna be bankrupt in two years
because you don't have a middle ground
here this is going to take you out with
a six thousand dollar income this is
gonna take you out and that's what's
gotten you on the phone so it's gotten
you thinking about this so we'll walk
with you but dude you cannot play with
this this is death by plastic that's
what you're facing if you don't put
these things up and chop them up and end
it it you know if you have a small
problem you can do a small adjustment
yeah but when you got a radical problem
you gotta do a radical adjustment I
agree Dave I'm with you and he's got to
get her on board they've got to sit down
and have a heart-to-heart today about
this situation because you're right I I
see bankruptcy in the future if they
don't if they don't make a change
they're not gonna fix it I know they can
fix it they just have to make that
decision so let me let me throw out one
more thing I mean the reason I'm leaning
on your brothers because I love you and
I want you to win at this
okay my fussing at you I've been right
where you are but this is like you
calling up the marriage counselor and
going we got serious marriage problems
my wife doesn't like the color of the
drapes
it's like a deflection the color the
drapes ain't the issue no you got other
issues okay
and sharing I might have argued about
the color of grapes a couple times but
that wasn't the problem
there's other problems dealing with me I
just tell you that I won't say anything
about her lovely gray DL because I'm
smarter than that I'm scared of her
everyone's here to puff this is the Dave
Ramsey show